abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
işte
nereye göreceğim yaz ortalıklarda
görevleri odası gibi gençlere daha
Allah'ım ya
de onunla biraz
[Müzik]
konuşması
gerçek değil ortası de biraz hasta
Gerçekten oluyor o
12hp deyince akıllı da
anahtar kelimeler var mı
Allah Allah bu kelimelerin izinde koşup
duruyoruz
ama burada aldığı
gibi bazı fikirler size dediğimizde işi
çok kritik olmaz mı
bu dünyanın sıcaklığı kaç derece oluruz
Bu video baktığımız zaman Aslında
Afrika'dan gelen o
bu ilgili birçok kaçınılmaz oluyor
oldukça tehlikeli
Evet Bu da bizim insanlık olarak
operasyonun nasıl ilerlediğini görüyoruz
Aslında 1 milyon kişi
karşıya çok kısa süre sonra
[Müzik]
bu ya da
Bir
sınıftaki arkadaşlar
olanlar bir
nüfusumuzun yapmak için
geçerli mi
38 yaklaşık yani sağlıklı bir insanların
süslü olsak Sadece büyük kanalda büyük
fotoğraf at
bu
dünyadaki süreci
Sizde bir tür
Dur
şu an yaşadığın an
Bu
duayı biraz çıkartıyoruz tabi ama Dua
bahsedeceğiz Aslında insanlık doğanın
içinde çok güzel bir parça et
[Müzik]
Bu da çok küçük basamaklar yaparak
dünyayı Kurtarmak eşit ama objektif
olmadığı sürece bu da
bu
doğru da ama sadece kalbimizi
tamam mı
[Müzik]
o da her türlü hizmeti teknoloji sahip
ulaşım çok daha fazla yani yakın Ama
biraz daha fazla bir parasal O yüzden
ulaşırım elektrikli araçlar geçmesi bu
için bir fayda sağlayabilir o
bu
karaburç Yok ya
[Müzik]
tamam ve
oldukça da
[Müzik]
3500 tarafından ise devlet
söyleyebilirim ilk beş bir kilogram
v510z azot oksitler özellikle bacak o
abone ol
bu burada arkası dediğim gibi bağırsak
Fermantasyon bir o
biz
o yüzden de o
ve bu ile bir aracı parlanın elbisesi
arkadaş yapan ülkeler alanlar ne kadar
fazla
insan var
mi Evet Doğrusu bütün sistem Aslında
yesin tamam artık ya Birisi şu şekilde
örüyoruz biri babasına kalkıp şekilde 1
de yenebilir o
[Müzik]
o zaman tüketim doğal ve elektrik üretim
a
[Müzik]
Bu güneş bu
herkes aynı mı
ama
sanki
böyle
yapıyoruz bu dünyada
yaklaşık 35 bin o
bu
fotoğraf
baskısı 2254 megabox 57 kilometre
karayolu
dünyanın en büyük o
[Müzik]
Allah
bizi karşıla nöbetçi Her şeyi boş ver
Burada gördüğünüz gibi biz o
12 formasyonları sömürge ulaşalım evimiz
ama
kıyasladığımızda
o yüzden de dikkat etmemiz gereken bu
tür talepleri karşılarken teknolojileri
a.ş.
[Müzik]
ama Asıl sorun Enerji değil aslında su
Sana gelen önce savaşta köpek olaydan
sonra
bu dünyada
hava o
Allah Allah Tabii ki Otomotiv giriş
yapması gerekir
Ama aldınız mı
[Müzik]
E tabi bu kadar böyle bir
Bu hafta
böyle
böyle bir
çalışma kültürü oluşturmamız gerekiyor
bilgiye doğru mu
[Müzik]
da onlarda neden çak daire kare dikkat
868 bir cevabı var
belli mi
[Müzik]
Ha bu arada bu A baktığımızda Yani
aslında ne kadar balonu ayrılıksa için
kullanıyorum diye baktığımızda Ama zaten
çok az bağlama baktım ki dolar cao
yapmamız lazım O
bu
hakimiyeti aldığımız var Getir sürece
onu bir parçası olduğumuz uzaklaşarak
Fatih olduğunu
[Müzik]
sonra o
[Alkış]